versuch mal dir diese fünf karten
einzuprägen fünf vier drei zwei eins was
für eine karte lag noch mal ganz rechts
gar nicht so einfach oder aber stell dir
mal vor du könntest alles was du siehst
oder lernst einfach so abspeichern und
das ohne es tagelang zu lernen fast wie
bei einem fotografischen gedächtnis nur
dass man es braucht stellvertretend für
alle prüfungen oder klausuren in der
schule aber auch alles andere wissen
will ich heute nicht nur fünf karten
auswendig lernen sondern den ganzen
stapel und zwar nicht nur den namen
sondern auch die reihenfolge und alle
eigenschaften man sollte zwar meinen
dass ich bei meinen videos mittlerweile
sachen relativ schnell lernen aber ich
brauche da noch was mit ein bisschen
mehr pepp gibt's ja nicht irgendein
trick ja so was gibt es für viele
menschen ist das lernen tatsächlich eine
art sport sie besitzen die fähigkeit
oder techniken um gewaltige datenmengen
innerhalb von kürzester zeit zu lernen
und danach fehlerfrei wieder zu geben
mit welchen tricks arbeiten diese genies
ich will herausfinden wozu ein
stinknormales gedächtnis in der lage ist
und innerhalb von nur fünf tagen meines
um ein vielfaches verbessern und zwar
mit einem gedanken palast
dieses video wird unterstützt von der
pokémon company so kraft
das sieht richtig heftig ich hatte als
kind nie eigene pokémon karten und habe
immer nur bei freunden zugeschaut
weshalb es mich riesig gefreut hat dass
mir die pokémon company einfach 5000
zutaten aus der neuen sammelkartenspiel
erweiterung schwert und schild farben
schock zugeschickt hat die ist seit dem
13 november erhältlich und hat viele
coole neue karten wie pikachu marie t
lied und monte carlo als wie max und
auch in ihrer giga den amex form wenn
ich in der zeit zurückreisen und meinem
12 jährige nicht von diesem moment
erzählen könnte wird es wahrscheinlich
laut schreien und weinen weil ich gerade
zum ersten mal selbst pokemon karten
auspacke und ich definitiv pokémon
trainer werden wollte bevor ich der
realität ins auge blicken und youtuber
werden musste von unserem 500 booster
pack opening findet ihr bei du in der
infobox und entgeht ein weiteres video
auf meinem zweiten kanal er dass es das
ist was hat der mann einfach mein laden
ausgeraubt
ich interessiere mich vor allem für die
pokémon an sich und will im idealfall
alle mit namen café typ und attacken
auswendiglernen ich werde dafür eine
extrem mächtige technik verwenden aber
dafür müssen wir erst mal wie gut mein
gedächtnis ohne tricks funktioniert
dafür suche ich mir erstmal ein
zum plan jeder karte raus mische den
stapel gründlich und teile ihnen dann in
22 exakt gleich hohe stapel karten von
denen ich nicht die reihenfolge kenne
und vernehmlich auch die eigenschaften
nicht kennen staffel 2 hebe ich mir fürs
finale auf und mit stapel 1 teste ich
jetzt mein gedächtnis am anfang des
experiments ist ohne irgendwelche
technik und ohne training eine stunde
genau wie jetzt let's go
ich fange erst mal an mir die
reihenfolge der ersten fünf zu merken
zama zehnter 110 kp typ kampf metall
rüstung atemberaubender schild ich habe
jetzt schon probleme motto nur 70 kg typ
kampf kratzer fokussiert faust 20
minuten sind vorbei
ich kann fünf stück vielleicht packt 15
aber je mehr desto schwieriger wird auch
tempo schwung
ok los geht's am centre 110 kampf metall
rüstung atemberaubender schild charakter
14 ich finde es gar nicht mal so
schlecht ich bin tatsächlich ziemlich
überrascht aber dann geht auch noch mehr
und ja da geht tatsächlich mehr und zwar
deutlich mit einem gedanken bzw
gedächtnis belastet auch bekannt durch
den fiktiven meisterdetektiv sherlock
holmes ein ort der nur im kopf existiert
eine eigene welt deren architekt nur du
bist und die du bist ins kleinste detail
gestalten kannst um dort alles wissen zu
speichern
ja ich habe auch nicht so wirklich eine
ahnung wie das läuft bei meiner
recherche wenn ich aber auch mehr
spannende videos für dem thema gestoßen
von youtube kanal alexander bauer
alexander wie genau kann meinen gedanken
palast jetzt helfen der gedanken palast
ist für dich wie sonaten notizbuch in
gedanken palast kannst du dich nicht mit
stiften reinschreiben da musst du mit
bildern reinschreiben und zwar mit
bildern die was tun
ein kriterium für ein gutes memo
technisches bild ist in der regel dass
du sehen und anfassen kann im idealfall
also ein ding freiheit kann man nicht
sehen kommen nicht anfassen
freiheitsstatue das kann man siegen kann
man anfassen das ist konkrete pokémon
haben natürlich den vorteil das ist
schon recht klare bilder sind also
pikachu kennt jeder das heißt du merken
ja dann verwende ich einfach nur
quatschen
diese bilder verbinde ich am besten noch
mit einer aktion auch da an sind pokémon
perfekt weil ich mir die attacken die
ich mir merken muss ja auch einfach
direkt vorstellen kann aber wie kommen
die pokemon und die informationen
eigentlich in den palast in jedem raum
eines pflasters werden zuerst objekte
verteilt auch klug genannt das kann ein
stuhl sein oder auch ein elefant je mehr
man damit interagieren kann desto besser
ist es für die geschichte die man daraus
spinnt um informationen damit zu
verknüpfen damit mir die ideen für räume
nicht ausgehen empfiehlt mir alex lieber
weniger räume also 5 und mehrere paläste
also drei zu bauen
denn damit sie sich gut einprägen
sollten die räume immer irgendwie
besonders sein
kurz gesagt man kann sich das verlies
des marat burg des zauberers leichter
merken als 27 schlafzimmer von herr
müller etage 7 oben rechts
ich schlage vor dass wir die grobe
struktur vom ersten gebäude bauen wir
haben einen baum untergrund nette einer
mitstreiterin der war der erste nicht
auf
gezeigt hat die ersten drei sind alle
übereinander jeweils mit einer menge
leute verbunden in die oberen räume
haben jeweils einen arzt an so dick ist
dass man dass man drauf sitzen kann
jeweils ja ja das ist cool der grund
wieso ich dich bitte mit den fragen der
solche details vorzustellen ist damit du
ein konkretes ziel für den ort bekommen
muss in deinem kopf ein eigenes ding
werden die details dienen dazu dass das
als ort für dich realer wird so
erstellen wir stück für stück meinen
ersten gedanken palast und mir meine
eigene welt so genau auszumalen macht
mir irgendwie echt wahnsinnig spaß es
ist schon echt ein ort an dem man
träumen kann euch habe ich meinen
gedanken palast übrigens mal in virtual
reality nachmodelliert damit ihr
zusammen mit mir in dieser welt
eintauchen könnt jetzt muss ich nur noch
lernen wie ich diese welt auch mit
wissen viele noch mal zurück zu den
pokémon wir haben hier hat beschlossen
die reihenfolge fest zu machen immer
name kp typ attacke attacke das heißt es
wäre vielleicht geschickt wäre für jeden
typ anstatt gegenstand und zur handlung
aus dem wasser ist dann vielleicht so
etwas wie übergießen das nächste sind
die kp da wollte ich dann doch das mayo
ist hierbei bringen hat das pokemon zb
170 kg fällt die null weg und wird
daraus eine 17 nach dem majorzsystem
also ein tee und einen g daraus kann man
dann zum beispiel die wörter teig oder
talk erzeugen dadurch dass sich kaffee
an den gegenstand und den pokémon typen
eine handlung zu weise entsteht eine
struktur mit der sich verrückte
geschichten fast von selbst schreiben
aber seht selbst es ist jetzt zwei tage
später und ich habe bewusst kein
einziges mal mehr an meinen gedanken
palast gedacht ich will jetzt wissen ob
die geschichten wirklich hängen
geblieben sind kann ich nicht wirklich
an alles erinnern
ich bin in meinen gedanken palast und in
meiner pace meine pace ist eine
raumschiffs des raumschiffes von außen
blau metallisch und hat eine typische
comichafte raketen form im inneren des
raumschiffs erwartet mich eine höhen
artige in wand und ein grauer boden in
der mitte des raums steht eine
kommandozentrale ja mein holzbett mit
metall fließen wir haben einen
kühlschrank der einfach so darstellt und
wir haben einen baum der in einem
erdbeer in den boden eingelassen wurde
wenn ich rausgehe erwartete mich ein
außerirdischer planeten mit
außerirdischen pflanzen mein erster
gedanke palast ist der hausbau eines
menschen der in den 60er jahren
denn auf diesem planet sesshaft geworden
ist und eben sehr naturbelassen in einem
baum lebt okay ich gehe jetzt in den
ersten raum der erste raum ist das
wohnzimmer wenn ich nach rechts gehe
haben wir einmal mit sehen hören riechen
schmecken fühlen als erstes sehen der
fernseher hier ist auch mein pokémon
abgespeichert ich betätige einen hebel
mit diesen hebel komme ich in einen
stall labor deswegen ist das vollkommen
star lobos so krass ich habe wirklich
die letzten zwei tage nicht mehr daran
gedacht das ist so lustig ich gehe quasi
das stahl labor und finde einen daumen
damals steht für die mdm steht für 13 13
530 das heißt für ein stadt logo hat 130
hp krass das stadtlabor hat 130 hp und
es vom typ metall jetzt die attacken
schlaghammer kann es sein ein
schlagbohrer neben ein schlagbohrer und
die die zweite attacke derjenige der den
daumen hinter liegen lassen hat hat den
ausgetauscht durch eine metall klar
meine zweite attacke ist deswegen
schlitzen de klar
crazy crazy dass wir uns geschichten so
viel besser merken können als bloße
zahlen und fakten liegt übrigens daran
dass wir grob gesagt danach selektiert
wurden eine geschichte mal lieber
spannend zu finden weil darin häufig
über lebenswichtige informationen
versteckt waren
der geschichts hassen der mensch hat am
lagerfeuer nicht aufgepasst als abonnent
wurde dass sich unten am teilen
säbelzahntiger rumtreibt naja und die
andern haben wir überlegt genau das
nutzen von mir auch aus und wir finden
es spannend wenn ein held ein riesiges
monster erlebt man weiß ja nie wann man
selber mal ansprechen muss wir wissen
jetzt dass ich damit auf jeden fall auf
lange zeit informationen speichern kann
und das ist richtig krass die frage ist
jetzt nur noch wie schnell ich möglichst
viele informationen in meinen gedanken
palast reinstopfen kann ich bin mal
gespannt ich bin mal gespannt was auch
die erste karte sein wird also das ist
natürlich der timer genau eine stunde ab
jetzt unsere erste bekommen ist
relatio das dürfte es sein das heißt wir
gehen in unseren hausbaum gehen im
wohnzimmer nach rechts und da steht ein
fernseher
ich setze mich also einen fernseher zum
relaxen
saxo ich drücke also mit meinem daumen
auf die fernbedienung dann geht der
fernseher an mir gefällt aber nicht was
sein programm läuft also habe ich den
fernseher kaputt damit als im berichts
der brechen farblos okay weil ich den
fernseher des bewohners des hausbauers
kaputt gemacht habe verpasst der mir
einen body svenja da ist mir dann
einfach auf schlimmen okay ist nicht die
eleganteste lösung aber ich glaube sogar
dass man weiter geht's
[Musik]
okay sei das vorbei ich habe mir jetzt
10 20 30 34 pokémon an geprägt ich bin
komplett kaputt im kopf die karten
bleiben jetzt verlegen damit ihr das
nochmal prüfen könnte wir gehen mal
woanders hin stellt euch mal vor ich
habe ich sagen mach das vierte pokémon
vergessen und dann noch weniger als am
anfang des videos okay hier sind wir in
unserem haus baum das erste zimmer ist
das wohnzimmer rechts ist der fernseher
am fernseher relaxe ich also rilax oder
android mit einem daumen auf die
fernbedienung daumen dm1 330 kps vierte
pokémon ist wir gehen zu sehen hören
riechen schmecken zur minibar ich
schieße glühen der rakete auf die
minibar also burak das prallt ab und
schießt an die decke wk 1 und 7
also 170 kg da die grünen rakete zündet
die decke an anzünden typ feuer
[Musik]
ich gehe auf den erst mit uns im grill
da geb ich methan drüber und sieben
metern
da es explodiert dann alles natürlich
ok baumhaus ist fertig ich meine
natürlich ausbauen
wir gehen rüber zur höhle in der höhle
ist der erste raum der eingang rechts
ist das radio das radio nämlich und
werbs auf einen celebrity also celebrity
us übrigens promi celebrity einer mich
an sally des brockens also das alibi des
liberty also der promi da fällt dadurch
von seinen skiern ski steht für die zahl
sechs das heißt wir als 60 kg
[Musik]
von bücherregal gehe ich rüber zur
tischtennisplatte also ich weiß das ist
pokémon trocken ist und das ist glaube
ich 120 hp hat aber die geschichte und
damit auch die attacken und ihr euch
vergessen dadurch dass in den look in
der geschichte habe komme ich da gar
nichts drauf ich komme gar nicht dann
der nächste wie viel waren das jetzt 32
zum vergleich am anfang waren es noch 14
also jetzt bin ich wirklich kaputt und
ich ganz schön kaum abwarten diesen
neuen skill in meiner nächsten selbst
experimente einzusetzen ihr könnt ja mal
schreiben ob mir sowas vielleicht sogar
eine schule benutzt aber ich finde es
nicht nur sparen sich alles merken zu
können sondern auch sich mental komplett
eigene neue welten zu erschaffen nach
seinen vorstellungen und träume und ich
hoffe ich konnte euch mit diesen
renderings ein bisschen in diese welt
mit
ich komme mir nicht nur doppelt so viele
karten in der gleichen zeit merken
sondern werde jetzt wahrscheinlich auch
echt lange zeit nicht mehr vergessen
werde ich mit der strategie von anfang
also keiner strategie alles nie feld
vergessen hat aber mein kopf ist schon
ganz schön was zum glück kann man mit
pokémon sammelkartenspiel spannenderes
machen als die auswendig zu lernen
können wir zu spielen alle infos zur
neuen erweiterung schwert und schild
farben stock findet ihr jetzt in der
video beschreibung und ich habe hier
noch ein paar zum auspacken also schaut
gerne mal auf meinem 2 kanal vorbei wenn
er sehen möchte was da sonst noch alles
drin ist und dann sehen wir zunächst mal
wieder mal gut und ja ich komme immer
noch nicht drauf krieg angesagt wird ist
dass ich von pokemon kiss fans wollte
[Musik]